most guys most teams are like their best players
to play at least you know half of the games if
you're playing you know six or seven preseason
games not like the old days Bush when he used to
play 10 or 11 I couldn't imagine that I mean you
talk you'd have to come up with a phantom injury
here the Avalanche getting a real nice opportunity
for four minutes four forwards on the I double for
high sticking tangelo on the bux drewan out for
Mar scar an early power play goal with Johansson
getting a piece of it Avalanche strike first
with the faceoff win that is the key and then
the Avalanche go to work here you see 12 and
white circling around he's letting high slot
area that's going to go back to the point drean
to Ma and then there's the quick little shot with
Lin and standing in front of the net no chance
for Thompson yeah it's tough for Thompson cuz
you got to look through the traffic of leing in in
front and that puck did drop an awfully difficult
early save for Thompson to make on the power
play and you know Mar car's so good at getting
it through and the Avalanche have themselves that
early lead oh what a stop there off the centering
feet from Tatar it's Tatar and watch this save
here by Thompson outstanding save for a guy that
just it wasn't going to work in in Colorado for
whatever reason so for new hook it can work out
in Montreal Johansson towards the net now in that
number two Center roll for the ABS McKinnon keeps
it alive Mar shot gets blocked both the DI led the
league in that category no skate play for Jonathan
marsho he blocked the shot Here Comes McKinnon
with speed McKinnon with a shot stick saved by
Thompson the safe thing is to just Retreat and
for Thompson fortunately he's a big enough guy
that if he plays on that goal line he still can be
big enough to make some saves one nothing Colorado
lead save made back gor have scramble in front
penalty coming up race for the fck fire and beat
Stevenson to it Steve cazer and beautiful play
there by Byrum Brady Hamilton referees tonight
Trent no Caleb Aon the liesman save made by
Thompson rebound score Ausin makes it two nothing
[Music] Colorado avoids escapes and then
now all of a sudden he draws two Vegas
golden KN players the one side of the
ice nushin Gerard the defenseman jumps
into the play and then there's a big fat
juicy rebound and nushin stops in front
andin Johnny on the spot as you mentioned
stopping in front of the net picking up the
Loose Change had something going there but
olon with the good stick on Theodore Here
Comes eichel moving in on gorv who makes
the stop Puck would never settle down
here yeah cuz if you're goalie sometimes that
puck rolling it can be awfully difficult to
pick it up off the stick yeah when
it's in front oh right off that near
post what a shot there by McKinnon
wearing fouron four action McKinnon
canot accept the pass McKinnon facing
out and then Stevenson with a great
chance Johanson already has a power play
goal tonight Steven wins the draw by the
way he was nice at Bruce to bring that
graphic with him that we saw a moment
ago now McKinnon and
[Applause] Maro here's Jonathan drean 3on
one McKinnon back for drewan and the save
by Thompson myself and [Applause] Michael
avalance one for four here's the Kinnon
stopped by Thompson beautiful pass there
from Lin an outstanding save quick release
there from McKinnon now McKinnon for ma under
a minute to go on the colar miner Michael got
a stick on that pass from marar marar for
McKinnon score three nothing Avalanche a
bullet off the Stick of Nathan mckinon
the second power play goal for the ABS
tonight remember we talked about a little
bit earlier with drewan the puck is right
in the Wheelhouse the other one he settled
and shot quickly this one here beautifully
executed by the Avalanche what I like about
drewan there you know you talk about moving
it quick but the patience to draw husin
scored at even strength during fouron four
Play here's a bount for Vegas backhand shot now
second in the leag in that department Edie last
season behind only his teammate Alec Martinez
golden knights led to Le in Block shots here's
barbashev for a cutting petrangelo slids it
across SC Nick W puts the golden knights on the
board you talk about patience with the puck
right in the middle of the ice and he finds
Alex petrangelo yor maybe gets a piece of this but
just great patience there from barbashev petrela
he could shoot it he waits he waits W opens
up and it finds the back of the net you know
it's funny right we were talking to Bruce Cassy
cleared ahead by drewan for linon what the Gate
of step on Stevenson McKinnon puts on the brakes
McKinnon back out drwan stopped by Thompson that's
good quick release there beautiful pass for
McKinnon what do you call those you call it a
governor here's eel Cuts away from McKinnon
towards the net barers have weights and that
is stopped by gor first penalty about to expire
here's W wood out of the box shot saved by gor
on barev and now the golden kns will go back to
the power play it is a hook for McKinnon real
solid night you can tell that he's ready to go
and he probably can't wait for opening night to
start in the regular season he has that ability
regardless if you're a fan or a broadcaster and
it'll be interesting to see how it plays out
for Sid the Kid and and the rest of that crew
in Pittsburgh there's no doubt that the golden
kns BR over there one PA G beating Alexander
Goram right on the inside he's able to rist it
and snap it I think it goes off the post and in
on goria but the advantage of having to stick
to the inside of the ice he gets it he Wings
it and then yes off the post the golden knights
pushing for that TI goal they've scored the last
two passing CL marf beats Gerard to it
now patrano for Theodore shot score we
are tied at three the flex it in front
beats gorf I think it was Mar so out
in front yes it was the Vegas golden kns
were pushing players on the ice for the
Avalanche but the shot from the middle of
the ice it's Jonathan Maro the MVP of the
Stanley Cup playoffs last year Theodore
B does a really nice job of walking the
middle and it opens up the lane and as
marsho is skating backwards or spinning
there's conter flips in around Gerard bym
looking [Applause] around bym hit hard by
conter keep an eye on Byron there he did not
like that hit store [Applause] conter with
a minute 17 remaining the golden knights
take their first lead of the night [Music]
develops in favor of Vegas well for B
Barum obviously he's got the history
of concussions and head injuries time
winding down here's barev one second
gold the knights wi it and come from
behind fashion the drill three nothing